اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من القدس اهلا بكم
مع دخول الهدنه المؤقته يومها الرابع
اسرائيل تتسلم قائمه باسماء 11د عش محتجزا
يتوقع اطلاق سراحهم اليوم في حين ينتظر
الفلسطينيون تحرير 39 اسيرا والاذاعه
الاسرائيليه تقول ان قطر تعمل على حل
مشكله تتعلق
بالاسماء الرئيس الامريكي يشكر امير قطر
على جهوده ويامل استمرار الهدنه طالما
استمر اطلاق سراح المحتجزين بينما اكد
رئيس الوزراء القطري العمل على تمديد
الهدنه وقالت حماس ان العمل جار على تحديد
مزيد من المحتجزين بهدف
تمديدها المدير العام للمستشفيات في غزه
يقول ان الوقود والمساعدات الطبيه لم تصل
حتى الان الى مستشفيات مدينه غزه وشمالي
القطاع والدفاع المدني يؤكد وجود مئات
الجثامين في محيط مستشفيي القدس والرنتيسي
في حين تحدث المركز الدولي للعداله
للفلسطينيين عن جمعه ادله بشان ارتكاب
اسرائيل اباده
جماعيه الجيش الاسرائيلي يطرد قائد سريه
ونائبه بعد انسحاب قواتهما من المعارك
احتجاجا على عدم تلق غطاء ناريا في مواجهه
مع القسام هذا وقد اطلق الجيش النار اليوم
باتجاه منازل شرقيه مخيم المغازي وسط
القطاع الاتحاد الاوروبي يقول ان اسرائيل
تجاوزت حد الدفاع عن النفس وان حماس ليست
مجرد مجموعه افراد بل هي فكره لا يمكن
قتلها من جهته عبر الاردن عن رفضه تهجير
الفلسطينيين وقال ان
قوضت حل الدولتين اما السعوديه فحملت
اسرائيل مسؤوليه العنف معتبره انه لا بديل
لحل الدولتين الى
اللقاء